مشاهدينا مرحبا بكم الى هذا الاخباريه قال
المستشار الالماني انه سيكون من الخطا
الفاتح التوقف تماما عن الحديث مع الرئيس
الروسي بعد مربوطين على الرغم من كل
الاختلافات معه
في هامر جائزه ماريون
دوينوفا لارينا
منظمه
ميموريال الحقيقيه الروسيه الحائزه على
جائزه نوبل للسلام اضاف انه من المهمه
ايضا يواصل مع الرئيس الفرنسي كان ممثلين
عن دول مجموعه السبعه السعيا للحوار مره
اخرى
الذي تحدث مع بوتين في الثاني من ديسمبر
انه تحدث عن الهجمات الروسيه على بنيه
التحتيه للطاقه في اوكرانيا واكد ان اساس
السلام الذي لا تمليه روسيا هو انسحاب
القوات الروسيه مضيفا ان الحرب لن تنتهي
بانتصار روسيا ونزاعتها
قال رئيس الفرنسي من وين ماكرون انه يعتزم
التحدث مع رئيس الوكاني الذي مارسينكي قبل
اجراء محادثات هاتفيه مع الرئيس الروسي
فلازم بوتن وكان مكرون قد ذكر في وقت سابق
انه سيناقش وضع الطاقه النوويه في
اوكرانيا مع بوتين بعد محادثات اجرها مع
المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه
وفقا لوكاله انباء سبورتنج الروسيه في
المقابل نقل موقع عن وزير الخارجيه
الامريكيه القوله لا يوجد مؤشر على ان
الرئيس
لتسويه في الحرب الدائره اوكرانيا اضافه
بلانكا في حديث دي محطه
يستخدم فصل الشتاء سلاحا ضد المدنيين
الاوكرانيين وصفا يمكن ما يقوم به بوتن
بالعمل لها
يحاول بوتين استخدامه فصل الشتاء سلاح عبر
تعطيل مصادر الكهرباء واغراق الشعب
الاوكراني في الظلام وتعريضهم للبرد بينما
هم مقبلون على فصل الشتاء هذا حقا سلوك
همجي ونحن ندفعه بقوه من خلال دعمنا
لاوكرانيا والتاكد من حصولهم على الدفاعات
الصاروخيه التي يحتاجونها والعمل على
تزويدهم بتجهيزات للبنيه التحتيه للطاقه
التي يحاول بوتن تدميرها
فصل الشتاء ضد بلادي لكن لا خيار امام
الاخرانيين سوى التحمل والنجاه للاقتراب
اكثر من النصر في كلمته اليوميه بان الجيش
الاوكرانيه افشل المخططات الروسيه
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزلندا
وصفه بعدوانها الى حمله عقبيه من خلال
استخدام
والحقيقه اكبر قدر ممكن من الالم
بالاوكرانيين
على مدونته استعداد الاتحاد الاوروبي لدعم
انشاء محكمه خاصه
جريمه العنوان الروسي
انتهاكشه المبادئ الاساسيه التي يقوم
عليها الامن الاوروبي وبانه منظمه الامن
والتعاون في اوروبا معرضه للخطر بسبب
العدوان الروسيه على اوكراني
في غضون ذلك نقل موقع بلومبرج عن المبعوث
الامريكي الى ايران روبرت مالي ان اداره
الرئيس جوبايدن ستركز بشان ايران على
ملفات اساسيه منها
روسيا بدلا من المحادثات المتوقفات ليحيى
الاتفاق النووي حديثا يتزامنوا مع لقاء
الروسي الايرانيين عسكريين في طهران جمع
نائبه وزير الدفاع الروسيه
وقائد الاركان الايرانيه اللواء محمد باقي
في اطار اجتماع رابع اللجنه المشتركه
للتعاون العسكري واكد باقي على ضروره
ترسيخ التعاون الايراني والروسي في اطار
الاهداف والمصالح الوطنيه لكل الطرفين من
اجل احلاله السلام من الاستقرار في
المنطقه على احد تعبيره
ووصلت معدات عسكريه امريكيه الى ميناء
جيلينيا في بولندا في اطار برنامج لاعاده
انتشار المعدات والقوات التابعه لحلف شمال
الاطلسي وتشكل هذه المعدات جزءا من حوالي
2400 مركبه وصلت الى بولندا واليونان خلال
الشهر الماضي من فرقه المشاه الاولى
التابعه للجيش الامريكي
تبدا دول الاتحاد الاوروبي اليوم الاثنين
العمل بسقف الاسعار الذي حدثته هدوء
مجموعه السبع لشراء النفط الروسيه
دولار البرميل
وكان الاتحاد الاوروبي ووافق على تحديد
السقف لسعر النفط الروسيه ومشتقاته سيحت
سيحرموا القرار وفق الاتحاد الاوروبي
موسكو كبير كبير من مصادر دخلها في حربها
على اوكرانيا ستكون هناك فتره انتقاليه
لمده 45 يوما تراجع الاسعار بعدها على ان
تكون هناك مراجعه دوريه كل شهرين للصف
الاسعار
ولو حنين رئيس الاسكندر نوفاك بخفضي بلاده
انتاجها من النفط ومشتقاته قائلا ان بلاده
لن تبيع النفط والمواد البتروليه الا
للدول التي تعمل وفق الشروط السوق حتى لو
تسبب ذلك في خفض الانتاج وهو ما اثار ما
خوفا من احتمال اضطراب اسواق الطاقه وكد
نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه ان فرض سقف على
اسعار النفط غير مقبول وان الروسي تعملوا
على وضع اليات لمنع امدادات النفطي
للبلدان التي ستضع سقفا الاسعار وقال ان
نبارك انا سوقا نفط العالميه في وضع افضل
مما كانت عليه منذ شهرين لكنه هناك حاله
من الغموض لا تزال قائمه فقط
من جانب الاخر اتفقت منظمه اوبك بلس على
تمديد العمل بسياساتها الحاليه في انتاج
النفط يشمل ذلك الابقاء على المسار الذي
اقر في اكتوبر تشرين الاول الماضي والقاضي
بخفض الانتاج بمليوني برميل يوميا حتى
نهايه العام 2023 جاء القرار بعدما اتفقت
مجموعه السبع واستراليا على فرض حد اقصى
لاسعار النفط الروسيه المنقوله بحرا ذكرت
رويترز انه وزراء في المجموعه اعتبره سقف
الاسعار
مثل الصين والهند التي رفضتا اداره الحرب
في اوكرانيا
قال المدعي العام الايراني محمد جعفر
منتظري ان الجهات التي انشات شرطه الاخلاق
اتخذت قرارا بوقف عمل المنظومه في هذه
المرحله واكد ان البرلمان والمجلس الاعلى
للثوره يبحثان مساله الحجاب وسيعللان
النتائج خلال اسبوعين
واوضح منتظري ان هناك جهودا تبذل لايجاد
حل مدروس والتعامل مع ظاهره عدم الالتزام
بالحجاب التي ازعجت الجميع بحسب تعبير
وزير الخارجيه الايرانيه حسين امين عبد
الاهيان الولايات المتحده ودولا اخرى
بالتشجيع الاحداث داخل بلاده بهدف الضغط
عليها لتقديم تنازلات وقال عبد الحيان
خلال مؤتمر الصحفيين في بلغراد ان السلطات
في طيران تستمع للمطالب السلميه لكنها
ترفض للتربه الاغتيالات على حد تعبيره
من اهداف الولايات المتحده الضغط لاجبار
ايران على الجلوس لطاوله المفاوضات وتقديم
تنازلات نسمع لمطالب السلميه لكننا لن
نسمح بالاضطرابات والاغتيالات في بلدنا
مشاهدينا انتهى هذا الموجز الاخبارين
نلتقي من جديد على راس السنه شكرا لكم
واينما كنتم فيها
[موسيقى]